Factoriza el máximo factor común de
4x a la cuarta "y" más 8x al cubo "y".
¿Ok? Entonces tenemos que hacer dos cosas, uno determinar el
máximo comun factor o máximo factor común de ambos monomios
y luego tenemos que factorizar lo de este binomio.
¿Ok? Recuerda que esto de máximo a mí me gusta ponerlo entre comillas,
porque no es máximo en un sentido numérico,
no conocemos quién es "x" y "y" y entonces, pues no sabemos si "y" es negativo
o si "x" es menor que 1, así que no podremos ordenarlo,
si no más bien, cuando hablamos de máximo factor común hablamos
de el factor que tiene pues la mayor cantidad de factores de ambos
monomios, y para determinar esto pues, lo primero que tenemos que hacer es factorizar cada uno de estos.
Déjame copiar el
4x a la cuarta "y" aquí, 4x a la cuarta "y"
y entonces para factorizarlo primero factorizamos este 4 en primos, que nos quedaría 2 por 2
y luego tenemos que
factorizar este "x" a la cuarta o bien bueno
desarrollarlo ponerlo con todas las "x", es "x" por "x" por "x" por  "x" esto de aquí es quizá la cuarta y luego
multiplicamos por esta "y"
por "y" esta "y" es un "y" a la 1 entonces, ahí está por "y".
Vamos a hacer lo mismo con el segundo monomio.
Entonces el segundo es 8x al cubo "y"
y eso de ahí, cuando lo factorizamos, bueno cuando factorizamos el 8 nos queda 2 por 2 por 2,
cuando factorizamos o cuando desarrollamos está "x" al cubo nos queda "x" por "x" por "x" y finalmente la "y",
pues otra vez nos queda por "y" ¿Verdad?.
Ahora ya que tenemos la factorización de ambos, lo que tenemos que hacer es ver cuáles son los factores,
o cuál es la mayor cantidad de factores que podemos tomar que estén en ambos.
Déjame marcarlos con este color blanco...
empezando con los 2 aquí tenemos 2, 2 de ellos y aquí arriba también tenemos,
perdón aquí abajo también tenemos 2
entonces, la máxima cantidad de 2 que vamos a poder tener son 2 entonces,
déjame ponerle por aquí 2 por 2 muy bien. Ahora vamos con las "x".
Aquí tenemos 3 "x" y aquí también tenemos 3, arriba hay 4 pero abajo no,
entonces máximo podemos tomar 3, estas 3 y estas 3 digamos ¿Va?.
Entonces, las copiamos aquí abajo por "x" por "x" por x" y finalmente con las "y"
bueno, pues ambas expresiones tienen "y", tienen "y" entonces, hay que multiplicar por "y" por una sola "y",
por que una "y" aparece en ambas.
Muy bien. Déjame desarrollar esto de acá, esto de aquí es igual a, bueno simplificarlo
es igual a 2 por 2 es 4
"x" por "x" por "x" es  "x" cubica
y finalmente tenemos "y"
muy bien entonces, ya tenemos el máximo factor común
y lo que queremos es, lo que queremos hacer es
factorizarlo de esta expresión de cada uno de los términos.
Entonces tenemos como que desdistribuirlo ¿Verdad?
Ponerlo aquí afuera 4x al cubo
por "y" y aquí adentro tenemos que poner una multiplicación,
para que nos quede lo mismo que aquí arriba,
como le hacemos para pensar en esto, a pues ve, este primer término lo voy a escribir como
4x a la cuarta, "x" a la cuarta "y",
el de arriba también lo voy a poner 8x al cubo "y"
pero ahora déjame dividir cada uno de estos entre 4x al cubo "y"
entre 4x al cubo "y".
Observa de acá acá, no cambiamos en nada de hecho puedes distribuir este 4x al cubo "y"
para ver que regresamos a la expresión original ¿Va?
Entonces puedes distribuirlo, ver que regresamos a este,
entonces ambas son iguales pero ahora si podemos simplificar lo de adentro.
¿Qué nos quedaría?
Afuera sería 4x al cubo "y" y adentro nos quedaría multiplicado por
a ver ,aquí tenemos que simplificar 4 entre 4 es 1 entonces no lo pongo,
luego "x" a la cuarta entre "x" al cubo
pues restamos los exponentes verdad 4 menos  3 es 1, nos queda "x"
y "y" entre "y" es 1 tampoco lo pongo, y a eso tengo que sumar,
tengo que sumar 8x al cubo "y" entre 4x al cubo "y" y el 8 entre el 4 es un 2
aquí pongo el 2 "x" al cubo se cancela con "x" al cubo y "y" también se cancela con "y"
muy bien. Entonces aquí tenemos la factorización que estábamos buscando.
Hay otra forma de pensarlo, hay otra forma de pensarlo.
Aprovechando que ya tenemos estas factorizaciones,
o sea si vamos a sacar el factor 4x al cubo "y"
de ambas entonces lo que estamos haciendo es sacar esta parte, digamos esta parte y esta parte de modo que
lo que nos sobraría en el primer término sería esta "x"
esta "x" y abajo pasa algo similar.
Estamos quitando esta parte, quitando esta parte y quitando esta parte,
que es el factor común y lo que sobra es este 2 es este
2 y por lo tanto adentro quedaría "x" más 2
justo como sucedió aquí ¿Va?
Entonces esa es una forma de pensarlo como lo que sobra,
y bueno finalmente no es necesario hacer todo esto.
Ahorita lo hice con mucha calma para ver de dónde salen
cada uno de los pasos
pero en realidad ya que agarramos un poco de práctica podríamos decir lo siguiente.
Voy a volver a copiar la expresión
4x a la cuarta "y" más 8x al cubo "y".
Entonces con un poco de práctica podríamos decir, bueno
¿Cuál es el máximo número que divide a 4 y 8?
¡Ah pues 4!
entonces ponemos el 4, la máxima potencia que divide a "x" a la cuarta y "x" al cubo ¡Ah! Pues "x" al cubo,
y además tenemos este "y" aquí y aquí, entonces "y"
y ya nada más como que uno lo piensa y dice ok ,
¿Cuánto me sobro? Pues este 4 este 4 ya lo saqué,
y aquí teníamos "x" a la cuarta y ya saque "x" al cubo entonces, ahí queda una "x"
y está "y" ya la saqué, no queda nada más y en el segundo sumando
tenemos que ya sacamos 4 pero, teníamos un 8
entonces quedan 2 y el "x" al cubo y el "y" también ya lo sacamos.
Entonces ya agarrando un poco de práctica vas a poder
factorizar el máximo factor factor común de un binomio de esta manera
bueno, nos vemos hasta la próxima.